welcome back to Westeros weekly we have
so much to discuss today much to the sky
I'm astronaut I'm Liana Galera and oh my
gosh the return of dendron Littlefinger
once again being the most manipulative
creepy person ever no get rid of temp
stare in the hand we've got a baby on
the way you've got a little baby on the
way baby lion on the way and also a
little special exclusive this week with
Brienne of Tarth herself Gwendoline
Christie I loved everything that she
said I'm so excited for you guys to see
it
but I think that we need to get right
into everything right now let's kick it
off with the Nights Watch Cersei
Lannister is pregnant this is not a
drill people
this is not a drill and she does not
care that people know that it's shammies
yes
Jaime's like hey so this is fantastic
I'm so happy for you but who are you
going to say as a father she goes I
don't care I'm queen it's yours it's
interesting because I think this is
going to change the way that Cersei
plays the game she cares about her
children more than anything else in the
world she's getting another one all of
her previous children are dead I think
this is going to be a whole new level of
her protecting this child completely
here's my thing do you think that this
baby will come to full term or do you
think that she's going to lose this
child again I think this is a bull often
filled fate for Cersei come on though I
think I gotta see this baby okay on one
hand I've always hated Cersei and on the
other hand when we get to see this tiny
moments of humanity and like she is
still a woman she's a grieving woman
she's lost her three kids this is her
chance till I kind of sound I'll start
anew and have an honest relationship
even if it is info even if it's whatever
brother
yeah I just got to go Mazal service
tomorrow sir we have the Tyrion and
Jaime reunion yeah very awesome to see I
would lay the user boys back together
back together um we should take a look
at this yes definitely you didn't hate
me because if anything I did he hated me
because of what I am a little monster
sent to punish him
I would sell obsessed that Jamie cut off
the speech because it was about to see
this Emmy we're doing this is here
Dinklage's moment for next year there's
like no what do you want but I mean
Jamie still willing to meet with Tyrion
uh props to Bronn for setting this up or
maybe not I remember uh because Cersei
was like oh I knew about the meeting she
knew about the meeting but I don't think
bran didn't tell her it's because she's
got her new little bird and all
throughout King's Landing but then she
said she was like John for trade or bran
for trade you betrayed you betrayed you
you got it it's Monday morning guys
Monday Martin deal with us
Ron betrayed yeah I don't really think
he did I think that Cersei just knows
that bran is the most loyal person to
Jaime and I think that she's just trying
to undercut any of that and I really
think that she only wants him to be
dependent on her and I really think
especially when she's like do not betray
me again that wasn't that was a threat
so do you think that jamie is going to
be the one to kill Cersei yes
I did too I mean they're setting up that
way because I don't think that it would
mean as much coming from Tyrion I used
to think it would be cheering I was like
a whole 100% behind that theory but I
just don't think that that is even going
to happen I agree but we know what has
happened is that Sam left the citadel
Sam left the Citadel dude you just got
there I kind of like the way they did
this because every time I see Sam and
Gilly I'm kind of like oh my god yawn I
don't care but everything that Sam does
is very significant it is but here's the
thing a lot of times he doesn't really
know that it's significant not in he'll
figure it out later but I understand why
he's been so frustrated they're seeing
all these old men who think that they
know everything and that they're not
willing to like take any risks or take
any chances and that's why Sam wants to
leave but at the same time I'm like you
wanted to be there for so long right and
then he's so frustrated that he I was
like I'm going to leave my job that he's
not even paying attention to Gilly
so he's suddenly incredibly smart and
reads all the time and she drops the
biggest ball biggest ball and this is it
we need to take a look at back at this
right now what does unknown mean it's
when a man sets aside his lawful wife
Maynard says here that he issued an
annulment for prince rhaegar
and remarried into someone else at the
same time in a secret ceremony in dawn
that's a common thing in the South Seas
maesters she was telling him there a
dark marries Liana and we had kids and
it was Jon Snow and he does miss it no
word has it he missed the entire thing
but he has such a great memory I feel
like no matter what he's still
processing it because he was only half
listening to her and then he repeated
back the fifteen thousand steps thing
but I don't know III think that gillies
got the secret she's kept a secret a
secret she an autopsy she's got the keys
to the kingdom
elsewhere in Winterfell let's go to
Winterfell because the successor reunion
that we have been waiting for all season
is not going as well as we not going
great bub and this is all because of
little finger finger and I don't know
why they're letting hands or ring
breathe the same air ISM at all just get
rid why is he still there go back to the
veil go back to be was like you're
creepy like nephew
so Arya is kind of stalking him around
she doesn't trust him yeah but little
singer knows that she's doing so he
plants this little seed which is a
letter that sponsor wrote in season one
that was like such a crazy throwback yes
I had completely forgotten about this
letter yeah so uh Cersei was threatening
something and kind of under duress she
wrote this letter basically saying that
her father was a traitor that's reason
and all of this and she wrote it to her
brother Rob the start via when Rob got
it he instantly was like no Sansa
wouldn't write this is under Cersei but
Arya doesn't know this yeah so she gets
she finds this letter hidden like a
magician you know mattress also who
thinks to look Marin now I'm going to be
checking everyone's mattresses I'll
check mine so now Arya has kind of this
smoking gun yeah maybe thanks and the
tensions between the Starks are building
obviously she doesn't like that
lady Sansa lady Stark was not listening
to everybody or was was not defending
Jones not defending Jon it was clear
when she was sitting there she's like
all of my lord
like I understand she can't actually say
like yeah I agree with you John
shouldn't have left but she's sitting
there and she's biding her time she's
sitting pretty hoping that eventually
they will take her as their queen of the
north then we'd have three Queens I love
her I think she's playing the game
correctly and that Aria needs to follow
really yeah whoa bulbs seat yeah I'm
like son with fans on this one sorry oh
I'm sorry I'm team Aria I'm Sansa why
don't you know what she's doing she's
smart she's smart but also she's picked
up everything that she knows from Cersei
who is one of the most conniving people
in Westeros Johanna is conniving
I think she's becoming sniping I think
that I think that it's in her it just
needs to emerge like a lion who well
that letter was about that little scroll
about the only major callback we have
another one so let's go to the north
remember I think this is going to be our
biggest the North remembers of the
season
yeah because get dream back get his back
I don't know if you're calling him
Gendry Baratheon yet okay because we
know that he is Robert Baratheon back to
his son but we have not seen him since
season 3 season 3 he was last seen
rowing his little boat away from
Dragonstone because sir Davos helped him
escape because the red woman tried to
kill him after she likes to do stim
because the Lord of Light told her do so
this is not the first time Lord wise
tried to tell her to kill someone
innocent and then he escaped thanks to
sir Davos thanks mr. Davos on a boat for
the last we saw he was rowing so I
absolutely love when they run into each
other and could look at this amazing
reference
he wasn't sure I'd find you thought you
might still be ruling so he's back and
he's swollen he's kind of hilarious he's
kind of cute too
yeah yeah we texted each other after but
we can get into this later but yeah back
in season one we can't sit we can say
that the stock in season one Ned which
kind of was picking up John Aaron's
quest of tracking down all the different
bastard children and trying to figure
out why and he met Gendry back then he
did instantly knew that he was Robert
Baratheon bastard
so once Joffrey became the illegitimate
king it was known that Gendry was unsafe
Gendry did not know at this point that
yeah was Robert bratty and faster but he
became unsafe left to go join the Nights
Watch mut re on the way I think they're
in love and well did you drop something
like that like a side note hurting it he
said he was a little of her okay that's
it
love is a two-way street I know that's
true I always continued back on your
back on my quest okay so he's going to
join the Nights Watch
yeah and then he kinda wants to join the
Brotherhood but then they sell him to
the red woman and that kind of where and
then that exactly happened so it's all
coming back full circle but I did love
when Sir Thomas is like hey so I don't
know if you'd be into this but we're
gonna leave and go back to Dragonstone
where you were last held captive what
are you saying he's like yep pack a bag
instantly super ready to go that's
awesome hammer here we go oh and he
knows how to use in let's take a look at
what happened last night
you're going to arrange to pay us more
than queen sir
this is Gendry he'll do gogo mouth
yeah he'll do he'll do feel do I love
when he meets job do they just instantly
well and I loved it right away like Sir
Thomas is like don't tell them who you
are and he's like hi I'm Gary Baratheon
so nice to meet some our fathers were
bastard BFF yeah like I guess why does
it matter anymore I guess he's supposed
to keep it secret but yeah they're like
honestly I think there's such good like
I'm there's a romance brewing right now
and I like it I love this whole these
holds this whole Seven Samurai thing but
we'll get to that in a minute yeah we'll
get to that
so I really enjoyed that Gendry watched
him kill those two Lannister guards with
his Warhammer it was super badass but
surprisingly it was not the iciest
moment of the night no it wasn't in fact
our ICS moment of the night is not as
icy as you might expect it's very hot it
is very very hot very hot because we had
to say goodbye to dick on and Randall we
hardly knew you well we hardly knew the
actor to play dead oh yeah because you
were recast that was really confusing it
was but let's take a look at some
specific cause
you
goodbye to all those series that dick
autumn Sansa will marry because he used
it who had that theory a lot of people
interesting now no sounds is too good
for you sorry dick on uh well listen of
this discussion right into our keeping
up with Elise's question for you yes is
she becoming more mad queen-like or less
mad queen-like
I think that she is just following her
word I think that she believes she's
being just yes I see what Tyrion is
starting to concern himself with but I
don't think so so here's my thing is
Tyrion actually concerned with her
actions that she's leaning into the mad
Queen part too much or is he just
concerned that he's losing control over
his Queen I think that too and also that
scene was really interesting because
when he was walking kind of through the
ashes these are all these were the
Lannisters yeah these were his people so
I think that he had this really
emotional connection to everything that
happened I guess was the first time that
he wasn't completely on board with who
she was killing
I agree but something that I was
completely on board with last night Jon
and the dragon coming face to face was
amazing and this was a real sign that
John had some dragon blood yeah he does
so when drove on initially came up to
him I was like oh my gosh this is how
he's going to die no but yeah right like
we're gonna kill Jon like that but I
thought this is such a beautiful scene
also I'm so upset the dragons aren't
real because this show just once and
again look at how amazing and gorgeous
that is that's really good and you can
see it in Danny's eyes - she's watching
him being like what did you see that she
had a name she had a lot of those
moments this episode but it also looked
like she was like yeah I think she's
feeling him oh I definitely think she's
feeling oh yeah definitely do you think
he likes her yes
how could you not alright that's true
that's true but I did like that she
stood up to him this or that he stood up
to her this week and was like hey sorry
I'm still a king yeah and he called
himself I've never heard him like really
refer to himself as I can yeah and then
she was like all right now
okay cool on the zoo but we did see a
lovely reunion between Danny and Jorah
which really warmed my heart I was
almost rootin for him for a moment you
think a little bit um I'm sorry do you I
think he's always just stuck in the
friend zone
oh yeah he's he's friends on forever and
I do love to that up kageura kids John
kind of this side I've like kind of like
every time I was get my girl there's
another guy there another guys look
sorry friend sound doesn't exist Jorah
but they parted ways yeah yet again but
honestly what did you think when Serge
or was like hey I'll kill the white
walkers for you did you think that like
just got there maybe I thought for a
moment maybe she wouldn't let him go but
I think she I mean I think it's
appropriate but he went yeah she's like
I'm I want on here to serve you whether
you serve you let me serve you I will
kill the white walkers I'm gonna know
they're really true but I'll go right so
alright we'll see we'll see how they do
moving on moving on it's time for this
week's wildfire effect size and it's
actually a very exciting week because
Ashley this girl right here who've known
and fallen in love with all these weeks
caught up with the one and only
Gwendoline Christie at comic-con it was
great she's very tall but it was very
off she is very tall and you're pretty
tall - oh you're taller than me thanks
for watching you interview her was
pretty much the greatest thing ever I
think we need to take a look at her
answers I'm going to give you five quick
question your answer them as fast as you
can work with it ready who's your
favorite character and why that's not
yourself I love sexy line of stuff
because she is a nasty piece of work she
is I will miss her if she goes and you
could bring one character back to life
who would it be
it has to be cousins dog I mean it felt
like she was a mother of the show
what would you like to see your
character accomplished before she died I
personally as a fan of the show loved
Brienne fight with the Hound and I would
love to see something resembling a
rematch on steroids
just like becoming a good guy I don't
know what's happening there which
unlikely came up would you like to see
before the end of the series Brienne and
Varys
because cognate Hill will make me cry
with laughter I can't think of any
greater joy I love him and at this point
I show which character do you think
deserves to sit on the earth I think it
could possibly be brand because I think
that the entire show could be a
projection from inside his mind you are
not the first person to say this and now
this is in my hub brand I find that
really interesting because on that
carpet multiple peoples have bet I don't
hope they're just like got together and
they really let's mess with ever because
I think book on that carpet so I really
feel like they're like boom I don't know
how people set that I don't know weird I
don't think that brand should rule up
more I think about no I don't want to
let's not open this plan we're not open
this can award let's take a look at who
is ruling right now and race to the iron
throne this week
okay so we have Cersei way up there
Danny is like almost tied now she took
the lead she took the wings you took the
lead because her she admitted today she
can't beat her she can't beat her yeah I
really she's gonna she's going to try to
outsmart her though she knows she can't
beat her yeah on the field she knows she
can beat her mentally she can beat her
mentally and then John of course like
he's he's meeting some progress but like
again he's like we keep saying he
doesn't care he doesn't care focus on
the real game of Thrones he is a real
king he made some progress he admitted
that he took it upon himself to like I'm
king of the north this is what I need to
do but you know they're going beyond the
wall we're going about where Crown's
don't matter this this episode was a lot
of setup and then we look at the preview
for next week and I'm like hmm
let's take a look yeah death is the
enemy
the first enemy and the last
[Music]
the enemy always wins
[Music]
I'm still needed fighting
[Music]
I'm scared okay what he's got
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chill we've got the Seven Samurai flash
Avengers flash Suicide Squad go and
beyond the law to with a weird plan to
kidnap a white Walker and bring it back
to Saracen I love it this exists like
what a crazy plan they're about to get
into like an epic battle but it's only
said they can just like grab one I'm
really worried about who someone is
going to da who do you think it is
someone fun to die okay they brought
back injury and kill them off one
episode later I am going to stop none I
don't I don't think that they'll kill
off country I think maybe this is the
time we're going to take a bite of the
Hound whoo yeah I'm thinking I don't
necessarily think that tour Mon is going
to go thank you I don't one week you
cried oh Jenny okay thank you but
because I love that he brought up
Brienne in the suture episode again so I
think we do need to have some sort of
resolution between these characters you
know I brought this up to a quantum when
Christine yes you did I was where I was
fighting for my man I mean she did not
seem like opposed to it at all huh she
was like I don't think bran like doorman
but I don't know let's take a look I
love Brienne but I might have to play
her because my man is going after her my
man tour Mon heal man my make-ahead in
what way to your mouth he is just the
best you love it I love him
well why does it Brienne I don't think
that male companionship is really angry
and agenda definitely I think there is
something of some significance of
causing Brienne R to give it some sort
but it isn't in the form of torment I
don't think I think that possibly
Brienne have a slightly more complex
relationship of someone else and perhaps
that takes up our fullest capacity and
but I do maybe it's the nature torment
advances whilst amusing they are not
really enticing
right she's a woman that is inspired and
attracted to something that resemble to
a mutual respect that's that's a
platform that's why she's operating from
range it's just like trying to get it in
I think she'll let you have him I think
I do I'll wear my shirt next week Ashley
has a shirt that is that tore one face I
do I'll wear it next week another thing
in that teaser was the Santha verse aria
dynamic which is building very quickly
very tense and I'm really concerned okay
so they they never really got along to
begin with there was always a lot of
tension in between them they're very
different women and they always have
been but they really haven't seen each
other for years and years and so you
would think that maybe they'd be just
glad that each other's alive but instead
it's just like sisterly catfights chaos
of the ladder and Littlefinger is
creating chaos in Winterfell you think
he's going to die this year no because
we hate him too much I think they're
gonna keep him around he said win or
something I hate this guy so freakin
much Nick I don't like your little
finger go away but I really do think
that the Hound is going to die next week
or he has to run out with Arya first
wait there's so many contingency plans
you do see the shot of Jon running in
front of Tora and I don't I'm not saying
that anything's gonna happen atonement
I'm just saying it really runs John run
on I also love that the night king has
like he was like night general oh he is
so scary yeah they all are verifying me
out more than the night king why I just
the heritage you seen too many means of
the night King just me like on the fun
yeah yeah the danzig what makes away
from the fright it really does it really
does
while he has it on that dance I think
that we're going to put in like the tiny
version of the guy like baby greeting
over here yeah let's figure that
bringing it bringing it all right you
guys that was a wacky episode but that's
it for this week thank you so much for
sticking with us this week we really
appreciate it we only have two more
episodes left oh my gosh leave in the
comments who you think is going to die
next week out of those Seven Samurai
Suicide Squad Avengers Justice League
guys shout out your comments
in the comments below talk to us on
Twitter there's going to be lower thirds
right here we're pretty sure be sure to
subscribe to e t--'s youtube page like
this video if you had fun and we'll see
you next time bye